this is part g let's have a look at what
they're asking us to do
show that this particular integral over
here which hopefully you recognize that
we just had a look at in part f is equal
to this other integral over here a bit
strange that you would see that the
process of integration leads you to
another integral but that's because as
we have done many times in this question
itself when you do integration by parts
because of the relationships of the
different components yes you get another
integral on the right hand side if you
started with an integral on the left and
it just depends on whether the integral
you get subsequently is easier to work
with than the integral you started with
and as you'll see for this question it
is going to be but we have to have the
later parts for that i'm getting ahead
of myself let's start by having a look
at this particular result on the left
hand side and what we can do to
manipulate it to get it towards the
right hand side
i've got the integral from naught to pi
on 2
just like a and b n since that's where
we built this from to begin with there's
the x squared term there
and then we've got this 1 minus 4x
squared on pi squared
all to the raised to the power of n
with respect to x okay now
when you have a look at a question like
this um because you've been doing this
so many times throughout this question
you might be tempted to think oh they're
not going to ask us do this again are
you but you'd be correct if you thought
i think this is going to be another
integration by parts because you've got
a classic sort of setup of your product
here just the question is well how am i
going to divide the product up in a
helpful way
when you have a look at the question it
does give you some clues right you can
see over here
in the integrand of the new integral
we've got this power n plus one and so
if you haven't think about the fact that
i've got n here well that will neatly
integrate up into the n plus one if i
choose this or something like it as my
dv right so if i'm going to choose that
as my dv the rest of the question is
well how do i arrange the rest of it to
make the integration most
straightforward what i would say is if
we want to make this equal to or
integrate up into this because you've
got a function of a function in here
you've got this 1 minus 4x squared on pi
squared
and that's all raised to the power of n
you're going to need reverse chain rule
to integrate this right so therefore it
will help us to have a think about what
is the derivative of the inside function
can i use that to help me arrange my u
and dv you know break up my original
integrand into a helpful product okay
now when you're working out what the
reverse chain rule will be
i need to think about the fact that the
1 is going to the inside derivative has
a 1 in it which will differentiate out
to 0 but then you've got this term here
right the minus 4x squared on pi squared
and once you differentiate this
hopefully you can see
let's actually just write it i think i
can sneak it in over here
derivative of uh
negative 4x squared on pi squared it's
going to end up with you know that minus
4 on pi squared is just a coefficient
that just hangs out the front but then
that 2 comes out and and doubles with it
right so you're going to get minus 8 on
pi squared and then an x right now what
i'd really like is it to make reverse
chain rule easier for myself
i want to see this derivative somewhere
in the integrand as well right now you
can see the the important part that we
need is there there's an x right in fact
there's not just an x there's an x
squared so i'll borrow one of those for
this reverse chain rule and while i'm at
it i'm also going to have a minus 8 on
pi squared appear inside the integrand
which means on the outside of the whole
integral i'm going to need to compensate
by multiplying by the reciprocal think
about that right minus 8 on pi squared
where do you see the reciprocal of that
in this question and the answer is you
can see it on the right hand side of the
result we need to prove right there's
the pi squared on eight so that's where
it's all going to play out okay
hopefully that gives you a bit of a map
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write this line here as
think about this for a second i'll leave
a bit of space right at that integral
from naught to pi on 2. i'm going to
leave one of the x's aside
and then the other x is going to attach
to
this reverse chain rule situation here
right so what i'm going to have is i'm
going to multiply that by
multiply by
the
minus 8x on pi squared that i would
actually like that'll be perfect to give
us the inside derivative so minus 8 x on
pi
squared
you can see that this x squared has
split apart into these two components
but i'm going to do this balancing act
right if i maybe i should have changed
the color here if i take that minus 8
and that pi
squared and then i'll make that a color
to make it obvious right
i'm going to put that same thing that's
reciprocal rather on the outside so
that's going to give me minus pi squared
on a so i actually haven't really
changed the question just dressed it up
a little differently right
and then you'll have the rest of the
integral so that's all of this which i
have not changed
over there on the right hand side okay
we're ready to go i'm set up i've got my
u and my uh
my dv uh appropriately chosen so let's
just do them one step at a time
if my u is equal to x that means that my
du on dx is simply going to be one so
that's nice
and then when i think about my dv on dx
i'm going to say well hold on a second
that is this long awkward thing that
i've written on the end
here right it's awkward but it's in
exactly the form that i need it if it is
indeed equal to this
am i going to cut i think i'm going to
miss the end there that's okay
i've got an extra thing on the side
okay that's all equal
to dv on dx let's keep that nice and
consistent there we go then when i
integrate up because that you know sort
of the this is the f dash
and this is the f of x that's raised to
the power of n all i need to do is to
increase the power by 1 and then divide
by the new power and then when i divide
by the inside derivative that's right
there it just kind of cancels out so
therefore over here and what did i just
say i'm going to work out v and i first
increase the power by one so that's
going to give me
i'll leave a bit of space
1 minus 4x squared on pi squared
all to the n plus 1 which is comforting
because look that's what i wanted right
there but then i also need to divide
by n plus one which is also encouraging
because look there it is there's the n
plus one it's supposed to appear so i'm
gonna go one on n plus one like so
all right excellent i've got all my
pieces so let's
use this to just continue our working
underneath and incorporate all the bits
and pieces from our integration by parts
i'm going to say this is equal to
i've still got this minus pi squared on
8 hanging out the front and it's going
to multiply by everything that you're
about to see so i'll just write some
really big braces there
and then comes the
uv from naught to pi on 2 right so let's
see what are we going to get here well
i've got the
x right um you can see that's come in
from from here and then uh my v is all
here so if i just grab that here we go
duplicate that right there so i've got a
multiplication okay
and that's going to go from naught to pi
on 2. so i'm just going to leave that
integral there briefly and then i've got
to subtract the integral from naught to
pi 2 of v
d u so
this is nice because it's kind of
exactly sort of what i want over here
this is the part that looks convenient
so my vdu is going to be
just this this is v and my du is just
one so i don't really need to worry
about it very much
okay and that's all with respect to x
okay
um don't forget uh we multiply the minus
pi squared on eight with the whole thing
so i finally got the whole thing so i'll
close my curly braces
all right now let's look at this mess
okay now when we evaluate uh the lower
boundary right that's nice this x is
just going to become zero so don't need
to worry about that the pilot is a
little trickier isn't it when you
evaluate the upper boundary the key term
is going to be in here because that's
the only other place that x appears in
this definite integral in the primitive
function right this is probably worth
noting down so i'm going to say
when x equals pi on 2
what happens to this particular term
inside the brackets well you get 1 minus
4
times pi on 2 there's the substitution
all divided by pi squared
right so
what that tells me is that i can say 1
minus okay look at it carefully right
you've got a pi squared on the numerator
pi squared and then a pi squared on the
denominator so they're going to go
cancel
cancel and then on the numerator you've
got 4 times a half squared so they're
also going to cancel cancel
cancel um so you're actually going to
get you know in terms of cancelling for
multiplication you're just going to get
1 over 1. so this is going to give you 0
just like the lower boundary did right
so you've seen it enough times you're
like okay i'm getting the hint right i'm
going to get
this term is no longer worrying about
multiplying by this it's just going to
multiply by this integral along the end
do take note there's a minus sign right
here minus sign right there so therefore
i'm not going to write a minus sign out
the front what do you get left with the
pi squared is still there on the top
you've got the 8 that's hanging out the
front the n plus 1 that's inside this
integral over here and then everything
else comes along which is actually the
result i wanted to prove right it's the
integral from naught to pi on 2 of
uh
1 minus
4x squared on pi squared
all to the power of n plus 1 dx so we
achieved our goal you might remember in
our original integral we had an x
squared there right and what we've sort
of done as it were is get that x squared
inside there which is why see there's
like an x squared here how many x
squareds were inside the brackets before
there were n of them well now when you
put one more in how many do you expect
answer or one more that's why there's an
n plus one and that is part g